good morning tickets Friday and my time
and then other ones is almost coming to
an end sadly there is so much that I
will miss about Amsterdam I will miss
the elm trees and the amazing public
transportation and my little slippery
view of the canal I'll miss the cafes
and the by cyclic abundance and living
in an apartment that is older than my
country and those are just the things
that I will miss that I can see outside
my window by the way and if you hear any
background noise that's mom say hi mom
your mother misses you
she'll come all the way to Amsterdam to
visit me but you don't see her in
Montana very often I don't know who the
favorite son is right now so a couple
notes about your last video first off
your punishments are very mean and I
will talk more about that when I get
back to the states secondly when you had
that ice cream truck that was playing
sexy back it reminded me of the one
thing that I won't miss about Amsterdam
and that is the soundtrack in the stores
so Hank you know when you're shopping
for stuff they generally pipe music in
so that you're happy and you want to
purchase goods and services right but
when they do that here they don't use
music they use real music which is great
but they also use a lot of gangster rap
and they don't like edit the lyrics so
basically your experience of buying baby
wipes and or shoes is like this I'm
gonna replace all the curse words with
the names of British Romantic poets I'm
a William Blake gangster so of course
you want my samuel taylor coleridge
you're gonna want to be all up in this
william wordsworth like Oh Percy Shelley
Oh Oh Percy Shelley I'm the Lord Byron
and Samuel Taylor Coleridge William
Blake it's just an unpleasant way to buy
diapers hang so I won't miss that but I
will miss a lot I want to thank all the
Belgian and Dutch nerdfighters who came
out to events and I also want to thank
the Dutch literature foundation for
making this possible
in other news Hank I was recently on
tour in home vain file under places that
seem made-up but aren't and a
nerdfighter gave me this this star won't
go out bracelet which I've been wearing
ever since because my this darling co-op
bracelet was broken by a member of my
household who will remain nameless
although he is quite small anyway Hank
the generosity of this president
reminded me to tell you that this star
won't go out bracelets are available at
dftba.com 100% of the proceeds go to
benefit this star won't go out a
foundation that was established in
memory of nerdfighter Esther Earl
all the money from this star won't go
out goes to support families who have
been affected by cancer
Hank believe it or not it's been almost
ten months since Esther died in that
we've raised more than $10,000 for this
star won't go out which i think is
pretty awesome nerdfighteria thank you
for your support and there is a link to
get your bracelet in the doobly-doo also
hank being on tour in the netherlands
has reminded me that you and i are going
on tour in the united states when my new
as yet untitled but soon to be titled
book comes out nerdfighters we really
want this tour to be amazing but we're
also not that creative for instance hank
did you know that the probable title of
my new novel was stolen from a
nerdfighter as in fact was like the
central observation over the book so
thanks nerdfighteria right so but we're
not that creative so we want to know
from you nerdfighteria what you would
like to see happen don't tell us where
you want us to go that's a separate
conversation just what you would like to
see what you would like to do what
should happen also one last question
nerdfighter would you like it if I read
the audiobook it's a little bit weird
because the book is narrated by a young
woman and I am NOT a young woman so
you'll hear my voice being like and then
I took off my bra she doesn't take off
her bra in the book that I can remember
but you know whatever I like might be a
little weird all right Hank I got to go
back to editing dftba I will see you on
Monday I got the day right nerdfighters